[Music]
hmm
it's really an honor to interview you
andy and to welcome you back to
berkeley um i don't know if you remember
but
i think the first time we met i was a
beginning grad student here in 1981
my first year and i think you had at the
same time arrived as a
as a professor in computer science yes
i think that you know this these were
really interesting times here in
berkeley uh you know in
in those in the early 80s and i wonder
if you can tell me
you know your experience of of berkeley
from that time
both uh you know both scientifically but
also
in every in other ways
i think coming to berkeley was quite an
experience for me uh especially
at that time it seems that that berkeley
is a place where the young kids are
running
wild i think partly because
at that time the the age of the modern
cryptography
was just starting
and berkeley
was the center of uh action
uh in try to formulating exactly
what the modern use of crypt
cryptography
would look like so i was fortunate
enough
to come here at that time and
able to take advantage of this
complexity
based cryptography which turned out to
be a very big thing
and and i got to know
many of the the shakers and movers here
and
i really benefit from
that intellectual venture at berkeley
and of course at that time that that you
know i i think the most wonderful thing
um it's not just the the scientific word
but
actually getting to know so many of the
uh the future great scientists there
including
uh umesh yourself yourself and
over the years that
my own research field actually
in many ways were influenced by the
people that i know at that time
and i remember that my encounter
with quantum computation
was was actually inspired by you when
you visited
princeton university and told me about
this great thing
of your work and what the uh richard
fireman
had started so that got me uh interested
in starting doing work
in the quantum computing myself so
i think that berkeley in
many many ways played a big part in my
scientific life
and also in my in my personal life and
um
definitely in in a very big way vice
versa you played a
huge role even though you stayed for for
for a year here at
berkeley where that your you know that
was a that was a pretty emphatic year
so i just wanted to um you know
um go back and see you know
when you arrived you you had the right
tools and the right
you know uh viewpoint to take advantage
of
of this of this uh you know wonderful
setting here
so can you describe you know what were
these what was this uh
training and tools and so on that you
brought to the
to the to the table that were you know
that was so
interesting i think perhaps a a
large part was my training as a
particle physicist and where the
uh the the philosophy
and the way to view the science
was somewhat different from that income
in computer science
and in physics the important thing is
very pragmatic you really want to
explain phenomena you want to
solve problems by whatever means you
have and mathematics is only one way of
doing it
so in a way for a physicist the
theorem statement is much more important
than the proof
and so i think that i was very
deeply influenced by that tradition and
therefore
when i started doing computer science
i i still had that in mind namely that
i would want to find what
was the the essential science behind it
and it's not just
just trying to find a good statement and
try to prove it but
really how to interpret it and just the
spirit of it
and and i thought that um
i think that kind of of approach
uh made it possible for me to explore in
some directions
that was not usually taken by
people who are just trained in
mathematics or in
computer science yeah
it was it was very interesting i i i
remember the
the course you taught that first year i
found it very uh
you know very stimulating probably
exactly for the reasons that you said
but of course you know when you say that
um
you went so much into into the proofs
but the statements
uh it's ironic because because there are
many proof techniques that are
that are really identified with you you
know there's uh
there's your house lemma for you know
there's uh
there's the hybrid argument uh which uh
which you used in your pseudo-randomness
uh
um you know they're they're just a
sequence of
of uh of techniques that you also
brought to the
table yeah well thank you i i think that
that um that by hindsight um
this by the by the present standard i
think that
that all those techniques were were
pretty pretty elementary
but i think that what you said uh
has some resonance in in my thinking
namely that that that basically
when i
kind of envisioned a certain result
and i spent all my energy in trying to
prove it
and i didn't care about the elegance
of the proof i only wanted to find some
way
of making it happen for example
improving asymptotics
when i think about big numbers i say
that i put the end to the 10
to the the 100 and and
so so i think that
that that when you are free
from the constraint of the
standard of elegance and and
you will be able to do things sometimes
more effectively namely that when i
prove things
uh usually uh well perhaps it's not so
much different from yours but but let me
say it from my viewpoint namely that
that that that i would like to to map
out the proof
in really a big way and then a lot of
things that we just take for granted
that it could be
that fit out later on yeah and uh so so
so in this way um i
i think i'm a little bit
more bold in in that fashion
so when i when i
told my wife saying that i think i have
proved the theorem
actually i think i i would be very far
away from proving it by the
standard uh that usually we have
in computer science and i wonder whether
you also
have that kind of organization
when you try to try to prove some some
theorems
yeah well definitely um you know i
i start with uh you know with
a feel that something must be true and
then
then try to get uh you know go at it the
probably more top-down that's what
you're describing it's a it's a more
top-down process yeah
yes very much and i i think this is uh
this this was some you know a reason
why uh um you know when
i found your work so appealing
yeah i think there is some sort of
rawness in my thinking
and i usually have difficulty
after i have proven theorem uh try to
write it up
in a elegant and and a precise fashion
because a lot of things were
done in an intuitive way and then
using a kind of patch up style
of making the proof to be barely passing
the rigor test and and and a lot of
times i would
i would get um
i think because in my youth i i i think
that i have this aggressiveness
in work i very quickly lose interest
in what i have proved and and i would be
much more attracted
to something that that
came into my attention
so you know just going back to something
you said earlier about getting the right
definitions and the right
uh formulations so that that's something
that you did a
you know there are several instances of
that
in well you know in terms of
pseudorandomness just just
getting the right definition of what it
meant to be
pseudorandom you know this
indistinguishability from
truly random or this millionaires
problem you know
you know get defining the problem you
know of
two millionaires trying to uh
trying to compare you know their wealth
and
without letting letting the other person
know anything other than
other than the direction of the
inequality so
it seems like um this this has been
something that you
you you did consistently in terms of
you know finding the right statements
yes i think that
that um i think basically i think
you and i are alike in that fashion that
we would like to
go down to the basics and would like to
find the
the uh
question and to
try to extract the essence of the most
critical and fundamental uh notion
of what we're trying to capture and so i
think in that fashion
we are
i think we are more like a i think we
are more like natural scientists
that that that actually treating the
subject
us as a uh
as a field of natural science and and
and and uh so it's no different
when the darwin was trying to understand
exactly how the world came about the
cities so i think that
in a way certainly speaking for myself
i would try to
read it and try to understand phenomena
and and
and also to to understand the
uh the difficulty
of uh formulating exactly what something
is
for example like pseudorandomness
because
before i propose that definition
i think people have different ways of
thinking about
what so the random number means because
it all started
with the statistics statistician of
having all these tests and when computer
scientists
came along we
computer scientists formulated some
notion of
pseudorandomness because they needed it
in order to solve some
particular cryptographic tasks
so it was i think from a
physicist's point of view you really
want to understand
not having a notion which
depends very much on what kind of
purpose you have
right and but instead you would like to
have a all-encompassing
notion so that it would apply to all
kind
of places
where you would need this definition
so so moving forward you know uh it
seems like um
one thing that's happened you know these
these notions like uh
you know uh distinguishability from you
know polynomial time
indistinguishability and so on
these have these have been built upon
you know there are there are these vast
structures that have been built upon it
and
theoretical computer science at this
point you know it's become very
sophisticated as you said
in terms of proof techniques and so on
but
is that you know and and that's that's a
great enterprise
moving forward but
where where do you think that this more
you know
this approach that you described in
terms of studying things as a natural
science
where do you think that fits in into the
future and do you have advice for
for young computer scientists and or
older computer scientists in terms of
uh theoretical computer scientists in
terms of what they should
how they they might uh think about
questions i think the the i think a
field
uh has a has a life
uh of it on of his own yeah
so if you hit the right
subject and uh you
started to introduce some concepts
and later on uh the field developed and
many people
have done wonderful work in it
then it i think it finds its its own way
into where it can be applied to and
becomes a big enterprise
i think that that exactly
what a young person should do and
in in at what stage that one should get
into this game
has a lot to do with a person's
temperament and the
technical background for me
i am much more attracted to the initial
stage
of something namely that to try to
translate
a a a a
a situation
when it's sort of chaotic that in the in
an area where there seems to be great
potential but
there's no systematic account
of the subject i think i i i like that
kind
of at the beginning and and plays
some role in transforming it
into something resembling
an order so that it's suitable
for for further investigation so that's
that's uh what attracted me most
but there are many great scientists who
who are good at in the in the middle
stage
where where to make things uh to acquire
more generosity
and more elegance and more applications
i think that it all depends on
what you want so my suggestion to the
young scientists would be that you
should experiment
with what you can do i think when you
are young
you really should let your
imagination and your enthusiasm run wild
that you should not take care of care
you should not care too much about your
health
i think that you should get up very
early and
and start thinking about province until
when you go to sleep
late at night and i think that during
that whole time
you should go to many talks and you
should try to
solve problems that you can understand
that interests you
and and it it doesn't matter whether it
fits your overall
plan i think that you should just try a
variety of things
and at some point you will start finding
what you are good at and and and what
you are most
enthusiastic about and when those things
clicked then uh you are on your way
to do something really significant you
know it's very interesting um
this was probably almost exactly the
same advice you used to give 35 years
ago
but about uh you remember that i you
know it struck me at that time that
uh you used to say well you know as a as
a as
uh as a young graduate student you know
it says you should really work on as
many you know just work on different
things and
uh and you know just go wherever your
you know whatever strikes your
imagination you can
you can do one thing later there was
there was another thing i i
remember you said at that time um which
was that
that you knew a few things really well
you didn't know that many things but the
few techniques that you knew you really
knew them extremely well and then you
applied them in many places
so do you remember i probably have said
that
and and and i think it's true and and
and
it's not just for my for myself i think
that
that that almost everyone has a limited
uh number of tricks that one is
particularly good at
yeah and um so i think uh
but i think it's true as ever
that you you shouldn't be too envious
of of other people's ability because
what i i have encountered many many
great
uh geniuses in my life
that that uh i think in almost
everything
there's somebody who can do it better
than i do
yeah but i but i think i can still find
my place
in the world because there's always
some combination that uh because i mean
nobody has the time
to solve everything in the world some
some time ago
10 15 years ago you you went back to
china
uh can you describe you know
what that's been like for you and where
things are going now
in china in terms of your institute
there and
what how you see it moving forward or
what what you've been
trying to accomplish there yeah i think
that going back to china
it's a i think it's a very exciting
adventure
i certainly did not didn't know
exactly what i would do in the ensuing
15 years
and by hindsight it's a
it's a pretty difficult process and i i
may not have the courage
of trying to do it if i know all the
things i need to do
but um it's a very worthwhile
journey when i when i first went back
uh i main purpose was really
to try to bring my
knowledge and experience and to
to educate the undergraduate students
and and perhaps to establish some
theoretical computer science group
and and turn out good
graduate students in that particular
area
but over time i
started taking on much more
than my original intent to do
and i started a
elite undergraduate class uh called yao
class now and it's very successful
and i started a quantum lab
so hiring physicists to build quantum
computers
and now after eight years it's
it already became one of the leading
labs in that area and
i also at the same time started an
institute for
interdisciplinary information sciences
so
this allowed me to to in some way
realize my dream
of of of combining
all the applications of computer science
together
in one place where people can
interact in a very intimate way
and so over
eight years for this institute
the first group of people that are hired
turn out to
to progress very well and are now
getting tenured
uh really they i was surprised that
after
a few years i suddenly realized
that they know more than i do in many
ways
so i'm very happy
with what i've been able to do
so i think in some way it's very
exciting because
i think it's the kind of opportunities
that i would not have been able to do
had i stayed
in the united states so do you
do you get time to do research or do you
yeah i thought it's pretty important to
keep one's research work no matter how
busy
you are of course i think there are
periods of time when you have to devote
a lot of more time
to the to the other aspect but
i i i think over the years i still
keep my my research going
and also keep my spirit in the
in the sense that that that i have
always want to do new things
and and so enter into new fields and in
the last
five years i entered into this
area of mechanism design and auctions
and and now into blockchains so
uh i always find it exciting
to to enter a field as i mentioned
before
that that uh something i i know is going
to be great
and and uh but it needed
people to uh uh especially
uh theoretical computer scientists uh to
you know to to solve problems in it tell
tell me about um
i guess what's now called itcs but it
was called ics you know the first
uh the the conference uh uh i guess the
first
two or three years it was held in china
and i think you uh
helped help launch it you know there
were many
many people who uh who
who felt there should be a new direction
for conferences in theoretical computer
science
i guess that that somehow in some ways
it it ties into this whole notion of
what are interesting questions to work
on or what
what the goal of theoretical computer
science should be or
at least what one of them should be yeah
i think that
this new conference indeed was started
in china that that the first two times
it was held
in in xinhua but later on it became
a very international and uh now is
taking place
in in in different continents
and i'm certainly you're one of the
the people who who co-founded
this conference with me and uh
i think that our original purpose we all
agree
is that um that we should kind of return
the theoretical computer science to its
roots in some way
because i think as a field becomes too
successful
and the tools
become too systematic and and have all
sorts of regulation
and and this you cannot do that you
cannot do and so on
i think it's um it's it's a
it's a necessity uh when something
becomes
big but on the other hand uh i think
that that we were
all worried at that time that the field
is losing
its mentality just because it's
the the conferences becomes too big
that that that is very hard
to to to to keep the original character
namely to uh be able to to get ideas out
while still is primitive stage because
the
the referee's comment can also be saying
that well this is a little bit
too preliminary and maybe you should
wait until
it gets more more solid but um
but actually i i just don't agree with
with with the that kind of approach
because it
it become more too much like an
enterprise
i i really like science is done
as a result by individual scientists
and we can all
present things in this most original
form and because that's the
form which benefit people most because
you let people see
your innermost thoughts in its original
way and
and because that's where all divided
vitality is
the process of transforming a
kind of problem uh in an undefined form
into a uh mathematical form
so that its conclusion can have an
impact i think that's the process that
um i think if i were watching movies i
think those who
would be very good movies for me uh
instead of movies which become
uh too much polished yeah yeah i see
um right yeah but maybe i should ask you
that
no you you know that especially you are
now
uh sharing that that uh
the the um that conference yeah yeah
that conference
how do you think the the no i i really
i really like the way you described it
you know this this whole notion that uh
um you know things that are too polished
uh
you know i mean they are they're
extremely nice to see but
um but some sometimes the you know
what what one values is how did it
emerge and the the original ideas can be
even more powerful and so if you can
grasp those you know that that's why
sometimes when you know um i
i used to go look up in the old days the
you know the
the proceedings of uh stock and for you
know those proceedings papers which were
much shorter unpolished you know much
more preliminary i found those much more
interesting to read than their final
journal papers sometimes you know they
obviously serve different purposes so
yeah i i really like that the thought uh
actually you know you were talking about
the state of that that you were worried
about the state of theoretical computer
science
back in those days you know that it was
getting too polished so what do you
think now
about the state of theoretical computer
science and also about
you know um you know what
how vital is it and i think there are
different ways of looking at it
i think that one way of judging uh
the the success of a field is that
how do people in that field
and do they do they like it the way it
is
and and they think that they are doing
the right thing and the most uh
uh uh approving things that that they'd
like to pursue
i think from that respect
i think the field student seems to be
doing well in that respect because i
think that
that that people are still very
enthusiastic
about about going to these flagship
uh conferences and really
treasure uh the acceptance by these
conferences and present their work
and uh so from that regard
my suspicion i haven't you know talked
to many people
about how how they feel from looking
from that perspective perhaps it's okay
it's it's
it's uh and also served a purpose i
think that those companies still have a
prestige
that are recognized by the
administration in
in in computer science in general
but for for myself that that
that
i think it will not be the right forum
for me to continue to publish in
in in those conferences i think that
people demand too much
too many details you know that nowadays
if you
you know you have to prove everything to
every epsilon and delta
so that people at least have a chance to
to examine it
uh i'm not so sure that that
that the a great conference
needs to be that scrimmage
about saying that we never make any
mistake and
and and i think it's a error correction
process
i think that that that i think if you
look at
the early days of quantum mechanics and
and you look at
the great people who have published
papers i think many of them by hindsight
probably would be wrong in their
interpretation and and
but it's precisely because of during
those
kind of effort that people come to to
uh to understand yeah that the essence
of the world
in in quantum uh i
i'm not sure our right now the the
process
that that um that we have
through these conferences it's uh uh
it's it is a way to achieve that purpose
uh uh but on the other hand i'm sure
that when people
have private contacts i think that um
they can get
uh those kind of interaction away from
the conferences for example every time i
talk to you
uh i particularly uh
delightful because i think that that you
always present
your latest work in in its most uh
uh in its most primitive
form it's it's something that that
show exactly uh the essence
of the problem and and i i really
uh i really enjoy oh thank you
those kind of insights so
i would hope that that that that
the conference that we started will
serve that purpose
i haven't kept track of it recently and
and i assume that it is fulfilling our
original view of so yeah
conception and um and and
and i i'm happy
that that that or because i think in the
beginning we were also
debating it wasn't it wasn't that easy
to come to a consensus
when you have some very uh
uh intellectually powerful people yeah
uh i i think that that that what
what comes out in the end i'm
i'm really happy i hope you will
continue to
serve as a as a forum
uh where one can see
that the continents get formed the stars
get formed i think that
that that that i i really would like to
see those
kind of things um
the the raw evolution of ideas
yeah in in conferences yeah
so so you know one thing that um that
comes up in
in what you've been talking about is
these
is these fields which are you know which
um
so which were at their you know they
were
they were in this early stage when they
were
you know as they were being created and
and
yeah you know uh uh creating the right
right paradigms and the concepts with
which to think about them
you know this this is something that has
always interested you and
so you know was that was that more true
in the early days of computer science
you know going back to the
to the early you know when you were in
berkeley in in the early 80s and
so on or do you see you know is do you
see that
even today you know after computer
science is so developed that
that there is a role for that or is
there is there is there a big role for
that now given how much computer science
is
evolving and changing and exploding and
so on yeah i think it has a bigger role
i i actually
think the opportunities are better
than 30 years ago when when when i was
at berkeley yeah i think that
certainly uh in the 1970s when i first
entered
the field there were few opportunities
for free thinking because there just
wasn't
enough material that you can
be creative about but as time go on that
the i think the 1980s
um uh it suddenly things be
you know that i think the 70s it was
still
in the process of continuing the
alan turing's you know yeah that this
undecidability
is a it's but uh to to make it into the
complexity realm uh but but
the the i think the real excitement
uh in theory computer science uh came
about as far as i'm concerned
is that when uh technology
uh progress became uh important
into the thinking of the aerial computer
science in the early 1980s
i think there was a
seismic event namely that suddenly
the mainframe really is start
getting to be relegated to a secondary
role and because the distributed
computing and the personal computer
came about and suddenly we can think
about network we can think about
even electronic commerce there were
far-sighted people who would thought
about it
and that led to the development of many
things for example communication
complexity
was one of them and just try to uh do it
and
and the cryptography the tv hellman
public key it's a way of reacting
to technology
and also in distributed computing people
uh
thought about how to how to build
reliable distributed systems
and so all these intellectual questions
uh
suddenly arose they are just just
myriads
of of such problems and
each of them has very very
uh kind of a deep
uh uh
has a very deep uh uh
meet behind it yeah so that it will you
it would
take people decades in order to
to make progress and and and and solve
them
and you see more such questions in the
future
exactly in the 1980s is the the the
distributed computing
and and in the in the 1990s
it was computational biology suddenly uh
the the computer science becomes
important and yeah
and uh i think it was a very
excruciating process
of trying to create a interdisciplinary
field and and finally i think that
that um people succeeded
in bridging the gap and uh then
in the early 2000s there was this this
algorithmic economics that mechanism
design
and because the google and the badoo
they were
you know they need to have ads option
and
so that's another input of a computer
sign
getting into that and not to mention
quantum computing
uh i think that you are one of the
probably the earliest
uh computer scientists who ventured into
into
into that area and so that's another
thing so we
we see that every 10 years
something big uh comes along and and
usually uh serious scientists sometimes
say
that oh it's just a hype right but but
but that's not true that that
that that anything that has a hypernet
usually
there is a a a big potential science
yeah that is related to it and like the
ai
and and uh i think that there's these
waves and
waves of uh technology change
that we are lucky to be computer
scientists and we we
we have the the uh
really very uh our
change in technology is many many times
faster in most
other uh scientific areas
and so we get to take advantage of the
technology change and we put our
theoretical expertise in it
so that to take full advantage of the
area and uh so i think that
that is i think it's really the most the
interesting time to be a theoretical
computer scientist and uh
and earlier today we were talking about
the
the a a many fields
uh seems to uh have share some
commonality and eventually
there might be a kind of a common
discipline of the
the real theoretical computer science i
would
i think that we should go to that land i
think that computer scientists
should move our mass and and
just drop what they are doing today in
most cases
and and do something new because i think
i think that
you'll find more reward yeah that's my
opinion i'm sure
that there will be people people will
will not like it
well on that optimistic note
well it's been a real real pleasure
hearing your views enjoy speaking with
you thank you
[Music]
bye